algorithmen und künstliche intelligenz
ohne sie läuft heute nichts mehr sie
machen vieles einfacher und schneller
und bequemer aber sie machen auch vieles
noch ungerechter und gefährlicher warum
dazu mehr in diesem video
[Musik]
algorithmen und ki sind überall auch in
der medizin von der prävention über das
screening diagnose und therapie bis hin
zur nachsorge
das heißt wir können schon vorher voraus
schauen ob jemand erkrankt und wie
schwer jemand erkrankt und hier anhand
der daten schon wie eben über den
algorithmus laufen erkennen ob ein
patient sein dass das schön in eine
niereninsuffizienz kommt oder nicht das
ist ein häufiges krankheitsbild auf der
intensivstation
silvia tun ist ärztin und professoren am
berlin institute of health seit jahren
befasst sie sich mit der digitalisierung
der medizin ein wichtiger aspekt dabei
algorithmen und ki die auch heute schon
vielfältig in allen medizinischen
bereichen eingesetzt werden
[Musik]
sein fortschritt in der medizin weil wir
weitere daten zur verfügung haben und
die daten natürlich
zusammengenommen sehr viel mehr wissen
generieren als ein einzelner kopf als
ein einziger mediziner oder eine
medizinerin durch die digitale
vernetzung von patientendaten soll es
möglich werden behandlungsprozesse zu
individualisieren und zu optimieren
in zukunft wird uns die digitale medizin
sogar zur nachsorge und therapie bis
nach hause begleiten gesundheits apps
und jerry buss die zb den puls messen
und die täglichen schritte zählen
gehören schon heute für viele zum alltag
sie ermöglichen es dass menschen die
eigenen gesundheitsdaten tracken und
therapien umsetzen klingt erst mal alles
nach fortschritt und könnte das
gesundheitswesen revolutionieren doch
alles hängt von der korrekten
programmierung der apps
was dabei alles schief gehen kann eine
ganze menge
diskriminierende karten in der medizin
kann natürlich zur falschen diagnostik
und therapie führen wir können die
patienten sicherheit nicht gewährleisten
und letztendlich kann natürlich es auch
zum tod führen
warum das erklärt uns so wir tun anhand
von symptomen jagger apps hier kann man
seine symptome eingeben und die app
sagen einem was man am besten tun soll
nein denkt auch ein ki und dann sagt mir
die app danach welche diagnose ich habe
oder ob ich jetzt mich ganz schnell ins
krankenhaus begeben soll oder mich
lieber aufs sofa setzen soll wenn ich
schwierigkeiten habe und da ist
tatsächlich es herausgefunden worden
dass männer die empfehlung bekommen ins
krankenhaus zu gehen bei den gleichen
symptomen die sie eingeben wie frauen ja
und die bei frauen sagt sie symptom
jacob dass sie sich besser außen soll
wie kann es sein dass frauen andere
diagnosen als männer bekommen darüber
später mehr
noch mal zurück auf anfangen algorithmen
sind so etwas wie geheime codes nicht
nur in der digitalen medizin sie
bestimmen auch unseren alltag das
autofahren die wohnungssuche ob wir
einen kredit bekommen und wenn wir daten
und so weiter aber was sind algorithmen
überhaupt zunächst mal werden
algorithmen von menschen geschrieben es
sind quasi anleitungen die dem computer
schritt für schritt sagen was er tun
soll um eine bestimmte aufgabe zu
bewältigen quasi wie ein kochrezept
nun ist es aber unmöglich die reale welt
mit ihren unzähligen möglichkeiten und
situationen in festen regeln abzubilden
an dem punkt werden algorithmen
entwickelt die selbst lernen sie können
in kurzer zeit viel komplexere
sachverhalte verarbeiten als ein mensch
in einzelne vorschrift beließen könnte
selbstlernende maschinen das ist dann
die künstliche intelligenz
algorithmen gibt es in seefeld esther
art gibt ganz einfache modelle die kann
man sich am besten vorstellen also ein
computerprogramm das einfach nur
bestimmte regeln ausführt also sowas wie
ein taschenrechner ich sag zum
taschenrechner die regel die regel ist 2
und 2 4 und der taschenrechner führt das
auf diese art madrid mit gibt es schon
seit langer zeit diesen rechtlich nicht
sehr bedenklich sandra wachter es
professoren und darauf spezialisiert
algorithmen daraufhin zu untersuchen ob
sie fehlerhaft oder diskriminierend sind
viel interessanter und ethisch
komplizierter sind machine learning
algorithmen hier gehe ich im algorithmus
nicht die regeln vor sondern das
interessante ist dass der algorithmus
die regeln selbst findet das heißt ich
setze daten zur verfügung und der
algorithmus findet interessante muster
und ob dieser stelle lernt die
algorithmen also selbst weiter und zwar
von den daten die ihnen ein mensch
vorgegeben hat genau hier liegt das
problem
algorithmen sind ein zweischneidiges
schwert ist ganz klar dass die
eingesetzt werden können für sehr sehr
gute dinge aber leider ist es eben auch
so dass sie sozusagen bereits
entstehende existierende
ungerechtigkeiten in unserer
gesellschaft erweitern können das heißt
leider sehr oft mit technik entwickelt
die dann diejenigen die ohnehin schon
sozial schwach sind noch stärker
belastet und das ist leider sehr oft der
fall für frauen zurück zur medizin genau
dort sind nämlich frauen diejenigen die
nachteile haben durch falsch
programmierte algorithmen silvia tun
sieht sogar eine gefahr für gesundheit
und leben denn offensichtlich
berücksichtigen algorithmen und
künstliche intelligenz im medizinischen
bereich nicht immer die anatomischen und
hormonellen unterschiede zwischen mann
und frau es kommt daher weil die
zugrunde liegenden daten meistens in der
forschung aus klinischen studien kommen
in diesen zulassungsstudien und hat man
in erster linie junge männer warum ist
das so weil frauen natürlich ein
gewisses risiko
inhärent haben dass sie schwanger werden
könnten es gibt da viel mehr hormonelle
schwankungen auch die vielleicht
studienergebnisse dann verfälschen und
dementsprechend haben wir eher männer in
den studien aus den studien generieren
wir daten also daten von männern die
dann als grundlage für die algorithmen
benutzt werden ich werde als frau
meistens über therapiert ja weil auf
basis der datenlage ja letztendlich die
dosierung zb für einen mann ausgerechnet
worden ist und nicht für eine frau das
ist natürlich hoch gefährlich ja also
wir könnten sogar bis das könnte sogar
hingehen bis zu einem tod durch
überdosierung
falsch programmierte algorithmen können
im schlimmsten fall zum tod führen für
silvia tun ist es da zwingt die
algorithmen immer wieder zu prüfen und
gegebenenfalls neu zu programmieren
und das sind unsere daten auf denen wir
dann die kali trainieren und die
algorithmen verstärken sich natürlich
auch noch mal selber ja und so kann man
sich das vorstellen dass dann diese
immer ungerechter wird je mehr die daten
die zu grunde liegenden tests und
trainings daten nämlich schon ungerecht
sind also es ist jetzt kein problem der
ki per se sondern ein problem der zu
grunde liegenden daten
es geht also um die datengrundlage
konkret bedeutet das dass medizinische
apps und andere tools die
digitalisierten medizin mit daten von
männern und frauen gleichermaßen
gefüttert werden müssen und dass
unterschiede von frauen und männern aber
auch von kindern und erwachsenen stärker
berücksichtigt werden müssen
die daten sind auf jeden fall vom wissen
alter weißer männer geprägt aber nur in
dem sinne in dem unsere ganze
gesellschaft
von alten weißen mann geprägt ist was
matthias spielkamp von der ngo the watch
damit meint es wäre sinnvoll dass frauen
auch an der programmierung von
algorithmen stecker mitarbeiten denn
bisher ist die branche sehr männlich und
weiß dominiert
2020 lag der frauenanteil in der
it-branche in deutschland bei 17 5
prozent noch weniger frauen arbeiten in
der kaffeebranche eine auswertung des
weltwirtschaftsforums zusammen mit dem
berufs netzwerk linkedin aus dem jahr
2018 zeigt in deutschland sind nur 16
prozent aller mitarbeiter innen weiblich
und der rest ist männlich und
da die algorithmen von menschen
geschrieben werden fließt auch deren
logik mit 1 macht schon irgendwie sinn
aber wir menschen haben ja
unterschiedliche vorlieben verzerrungen
und vorurteile und die werden natürlich
in den daten erfasst deshalb geld
diskriminierende algorithmen finden sich
nicht nur in der medizin sondern in
zahlreichen anderen lebensbereichen das
schlimme daran wenn ein ungerechtes
system in einem algorithmus codiert ist
wird es quasi festgeschrieben
es gibt noch andere beispiele bei denen
nicht nur algorithmen menschen
benachteiligen auch bei
infrarottechnologie die zb bei türen
fotoautomaten oder seifenspendern
eingesetzt wird kann es passieren dass
zum beispiel schwarze menschen nicht
erkannt werden und die technik nicht
funktioniert
aber wie geht das genau
infrarot technologie zb reagiert auf
licht reflexionen auf der haut und löst
aus wenn ein bestimmter wert
überschritten wird der dunkle haut
weniger licht reflektiert als helle wird
der grenzwert nicht überschritten das
system reagiert nicht bei digitaler
diskriminierung kommt erschwerend hinzu
viele opfer können selbst gar nicht
nachvollziehen warum ein gerät oder ein
prozess nicht funktioniert oder warum
ihnen bei suchanfragen im internet nur
bestimmte geschlechtsspezifische inhalte
angeboten werden es gibt weitere
beispiele wie verborgene code dazu
führen dass die ungleichheit in unserer
gesellschaft noch verstärkt wird
über die hintergründe und wie wir alle
davon betroffen sind davon handelt die
erste folge unserer doku reihe digital
empire wir haben mit menschen gesprochen
die opfer von diskriminierenden
algorithmen infrarot technik und kaffee
wurden
mit tanja einer influenza in deren
beiträge auf instagram nicht so
ausgespielt werden wie die von dünnen
menschen und die außerdem vermehrt opfer
von hass kommentaren ist und wir haben
denn getroffen die im realen leben
diskriminierung erfährt und im netz
ebenfalls doch da kann sie sich nicht
wehrt
digitale diskriminierungen geht weit
über medizin und nicht auslösende
seifenspender hinaus aber es gibt auch
bestrebungen das zu ende wie das
gelingen kann darüber sprechen zum
beispiel der abgeordnete amazon und die
ki experten kennt sie aber in unserer
doku programmierte ungerecht können
den link findet ihr hier
regazzoni
[Musik]